pour trouver la tombe de yul brynner il
y a d'abord tout une prairie a traversé
au fond un petit cimetière orthodoxe
le propriétaire des lieux nous sert de
guide voir l'icône orthodoxe puisque le
cimetière à l'origine
orthodoxe la pente de l'auteur
l'acteur qui est russe à l'origine
puisqu'il aimait à vladivostok une tombe
très modestes dans un cimetière lui
aussi modeste comment imaginer qu'en
dessous reposent les cendres d'une star
du cinéma hollywoodien mondialement
connu un lieu qui attire son lot de
visiteurs
j'ai deux types de visiteurs certains
qui viennent pour l'abbaye certains qui
viennent pour green r j'ai différents
les américains bien sûr qu'ils sont
intéressés par le personnage les russes
également puisqu'il est d'origine russe
vous avez aussi toute une clientèle qui
s'amusent à faire le cimetière donc ça
c'est un peu un peu différent et puis
alors vous avez par exemple pas mal de
gens qui s'assimilent physiquement le
bonheur des gens qui sont chaudes et
notamment j'ai toute une clientèle situe
au niveau des motards yul brynner
acteurs bien connus des baby boomers
l'homme au crâne rasé stars du cinéma
des années 50 60 et 70
oscar du meilleur acteur en 1957 a joué
dans une quarantaine de films le voici
en 1956 sublimée par le technicolor dans
le péplum les dix commandements
ou en 1959 dans un film français de jean
cocteau le testament d'orphée fait voler
quelques minutes
monsieur le ministre va recevoir
l'homme parle très bien le français
comme de nombreuses langues d'ailleurs
après avoir émigré de russie puis de
chine il s'installe avec sa famille en
france un pays qu'il ne quittera jamais
malgré sa carrière américaine il est le
propriétaire d'une villa en normandie il
est aussi le parrain de nathalie rheims
et de charlotte gainsbourg fumeur
invétéré il meurt le 10 octobre 1985
d'un cancer des poumons mais pourquoi
yul brynner et il enterré en touraine
alors qu'il n'y a jamais vécu
l'explication se trouve du côté de sa
religion yul brynner et et orthodoxes il
est décédé à new york il a été incinéré
et puis ses cendres ont été rapatriées
en normandie en normandie parce que son
épouse ville a donc sa quatrième épouse
qui a décidé abandonné de revendre la
ville a décidé de transférer ses cendres
à paris ça ne s'est pas fait et ça
dérivés sur luz et parce qu'à l'époque
il y avait une communauté orthodoxe qui
occupaient les lieux ans il se fait que
dans cette communauté il y avait un
moine
et qui a proposé de ramener les cendres
et 6-2 en une heure demain les deux
associations autour de l'abbaye de bois
aubry célébreront les 30 ans de la mort
de l'acteur un dépôt de gerbe est prévu
le matin et toute la journée le site
sera ouvert pour les visites une
célébration modeste à l'image peut être
du personnage dans les années 60 yul
brynner avoué à la télévision française
regretter l'époque où il était un simple
citoyen anonyme